le parti québécois a présenté son cadre
financier quatrième partie à le faire le
pq prévoit s'il est porté au pouvoir une
réduction importante des versements au
fonds des générations de 50 à 60 de 50 à
60% pour financer près de 30 milliards
de dollars de nouvelles dépenses sur
cinq ans 11 milliards iraient à la
transition énergétique 8 milliards en
baisses d'impôts pour les 60 à 69 ans
pour exemptés d'impôts les derniers
35000 dollars de revenus pour les 60 à
69 ans près de 8 milliards de dollars
pour les soins à domicile et 6 milliards
300 millions en allocation spéciale pour
contrer l'inflation déficit prévu de 4
milliards 649 millions de dollars en
2000 22 23 retour des surplus et retour
aux déficits en 2000 26 27 avec nous
pour en parler ce soir alexis gagnon
lebrun alexis gagné lebrun kyoto
candidat du parti québécois dans
saint-hyacinthe bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes professeur vous au cégep de
saint-hyacinthe professeur de physique
détenteur de trois maîtrise en physique
en éducation et en économie qu'est ce
qui vous motive à vous lancer dans dans
la course ça fait une bonne vingtaine
d'années que je milite au parti
québécois dont les cinq dernières chutes
à l'exécutif national donc j'ai été au
cas où ce virage compte qu'on a amené au
parti québécois de modernisation de sa
fenêtre l'indépendance au coeur de notre
projet de s'assumer ce qui nous a mené à
l'élection de paul comme chef et
maintenant la campagne électorale donc
vous vous lancez et dans le programme
qui est présenté dans le cadre financier
qui a été présentée aujourd'hui on voit
que vous venez réduire de moitié les
sommes injectées au fonds des
générations pour investir dans la
transition pour atteindre aussi il faut
dire l'équilibré budgétaire pourquoi
couper dans le fond qui est quand même
un outil de stabilité financière et
d'équité intergénérationnelle
honda corse pour ça qu'on a menti une
partie importante du fonds pour ces
raisons là par contre quand on parle du
fonds des générations si on n'a pas un
avenir de qualité sont assombries du
sport de manière importante notre
production de gaz à effet de serre on
n'aura pas un avenir de qualité pour
nous les générations à venir donc c'est
l'équilibré qu'on amène comme nous avait
dit au début du mandat c'est ce 60% à
peu près de détection des versements
mais vers la fin de ce mandat c'est plus
par 50% comme le fonds des générations
ayant une croissance importante on pense
que votre le standard 50% sion ça on
avait conduit 2 le cadre financier à
plus long terme donc c'est vraiment une
éclipse de dire qu'il faut quand même
s'attaquer en ce moment la crise
climatique c'est urgent et c'est normal
qu'on a cherché un peu dans ce fonds
l'autre que de côté parce qu'ils ont une
croissance est d'accord qu'un peu tout
le monde a ses raisons en ce moment pour
aller dans le fonds des générations pour
piger dans le fonds des générations
vous pensez que ça doit aller qu'il faut
remettre en question le fonds des
générations puisque voulait puiser la
moitié des versements on ne remet pas en
question le fond c'est peut-être
l'importance qu'ont con mais tient dans
le versement dans l'addition de nouveaux
versements compte qu'on ajoute la tuerie
ne remet pas en question le fonds n'a
jamais été contre l'existence de son
compte quand même d'autres pions c'est
très important le fait pas pour des
baisses d'impôts le nous ont faits pour
eux pour la crise climatique la location
au pouvoir d'achat qui est un chèque
comme la caq dans le fond vous voulez
envoyer une bonne partie de la
population ces 6 milliards 300 millions
de plus d'un coup dans l'économie est ce
que c'est pas d'alimenter l'inflation
c'est ce qui peut avoir des effets mais
les personnes en ont besoin c'est
important quand on nous on vise vraiment
les personnes les plus vulnérables donc
les montants les plus importants c'est
pour les cinquante mille dollars et me
les personnes qui gagnent 50 mille
dollars et moins c'est qu'ils vont la
grande partie neil 200 dollars par
personne 750 1 pour ceux qui y entrent
50 milles 90 les personnes en ont besoin
ils voulaient en v'là des présenté
tantôt sur les les besoins des personnes
de coûts la vie est là la hausse du prix
de l'essence donc il faut qu'on ait une
personne pour pouvoir passer à
travailler une mesure pour contrer
l'inflation ne peut pas être une mesure
qui est inflationniste c'est une mesure
pour aider le pouvoir d'achat c'est
vraiment sur le but aux gens doivent
alimenter l'inflation vous pensez pas
mais moins un an selon nous que les
baisses d'impôts parce qu'ils ont ils
vraiment localiser ça va aider les
personnes à pouvoir
ah vraiment souvenirs à leurs besoins et
moi je fais du porte-à-porte qu'on m'en
parlait de la hausse du coût de
l'alimentation
de l'essence on m'en parle tous les
jours donc c'est important que l'état
est là pour aider son monde dans les
mesures quand même assez forte que vous
présentez aujourd'hui vous proposer que
les personnes de 60 ans et plus qui font
50 mille dollars et moins ne paient plus
d'impôts
verizon et de 50000 à 80000 un incitatif
pour rester au travail avec un rabais
d'imposition et un arrêt des cotisations
au régime des rentes du québec pour les
65 ans et plus ces quelques milliards le
coût quand même là est ce que pour vous
les travailleurs expérimentés c'est la
solution à la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
c'est une solution très importante à la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre ce pôle il faut
faire un cocktail de mesures pour nous
aider à pas cela à amenuiser les fait de
la pénurie de main d'oeuvre mais c'est
vraiment une des solutions les plus
importantes pour ça effectivement qu'on
qu'on met beaucoup d'argent là dedans
par contre cet argent là on pense qu'il
va revenir à l'état parce que les
personnes si on réussit à amener des
personnes sur le marché du travail ils
vont payer des taxes des impôts ils vont
surtout contribué à augmenter la
production des entreprises qui elles
vont donc payer plus d'impôts en retour
à la société par là par leurs impôts des
sociétés mais vous ne comptez pas
beaucoup sur l'immigration pour combler
la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre parce que
vous voulez baisser le seuil à 35 mille
nouveaux immigrants accueillis or on a
quand même une population active qui
équipent en décroissance mais pas loin
là on est quand même en faible
croissance de la population active ça va
nous prendre des bras un moment donné
est ce que ce que vous craignez pas que
votre proposition d'abaisser les seuils
d'immigration soit nuisible à l'économie
du québec maintenant parce qu'on regarde
la science et études économiques
démographiques
qu'est-ce qu'on se rend compte que
l'immigration est relativement neutre
par rapport à aux pénuries de main
d'oeuvre si elle est généralisée ciel et
sectorielles c'est sûr qu'on peut amener
des personnes dans ce secteur là et le
sabre aidé par contre il va manquer de
logements de manquer de ces places en
cpe il va manquer de personnes à
l'épicerie donc les personnes qui
viennent travailler comme tout le monde
on consomme on vit au québec donc on
crée on a besoin d'emplois l'équivalent
de dire que si on annexes par exemple le
vermont québec lé on eu plusieurs
personnes tout d'un coup une immigration
massive
est-ce qu'on a moins de pénurie main
d'oeuvre le lendemain c'est la même
situation au vermont qui si donc on se
retrouve avec un jeu à somme nulle dans
cette situation là parce que ça va aider
les entreprises
nous on n'est pas pdg d'une entreprise
on veut gérer l'état et quand on regarde
les besoins de l'état dans son ensemble
ça marche pas je comprends mais notre
population active croît très lentement
et votre croître lentement dans les
prochaines années avec un vieillissement
de la population nos voisins ont une
croissance de population active qui est
quand même plus élevé est-ce qu'on joue
pas en désavantage numérique est ce que
l'immigration ne devrait pas faire
partie des outils essentiels à la
croissance future d'économie du québec
mais quand on regarde les études de
manière générale et pau si on regarde
une pénurie sectorielle parce que c'est
pas notre situation
il en train de sa peau d'un effet sur
l'aca va pas aider à régler la pénurie
de main-d'oeuvre pourquoi parce qu'on
crée autant de consommation que de
quelqu'un comme des besoins de main
d'oeuvre donc oui on va avoir plus de
population va produire plus mais on va
avoir encore besoin de plus de
main-d'oeuvre pour combler la nouvelle
consommation des personnes qui vont
venir nous rejoindre les états unis vous
l'avez dit on plus grande croissance que
nous en terme de nombre de personnes
mais est-ce qu'ils ont moins de pénurie
de main d'oeuvre que nous non le canada
également l'exact même et pourtant ayant
rien ils reçoivent beaucoup d'émigrés à
la même chose pour l'ontario reçoivent
beaucoup mêmes et donc il y aura pas et
ça ça change rien les études économiques
et démographiques de manière généralisée
sont assez claires le nord fermiers vos
arguments votre explication là dessus
merci beaucoup pink turtle merci bien
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit